[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARA SOSS: Welcome to our
session covering the Google
Cloud Security Engineer Training
and Professional Google Cloud
Security Engineer Certification.
We have some great
opportunities to share
with you and your teams.
I'm Mara Soss, the Google Cloud
Credentials Engagement lead.
Now, the market demand
for security engineers
is undeniable.
Our partners and
customers are looking
for individuals with the
validated, certified skills
to help with their toughest
security challenges.
Recently collected data
illustrates the 83%
of Google Cloud certified
professionals feel
their resume is more attractive
after a certification.
The same report states
that 87% of Google Cloud
certified individuals are more
confident about their Cloud
skills.
And finally, the report found
that 71% of Google Cloud
certified individuals report
that becoming certified
enabled or will enable their
employer to get more business,
increase work with
existing customers,
or help scale up their business.
These valuable insights
speak to the opportunity
that investing in Google Cloud
training and certification
can bring to both your
career and your organization.
So to talk more about this
opportunity, I welcome Erin.
AARON SUTTON: I'm Aaron
Sutton, a strategic Cloud
engineer with Google Cloud
Professional Services,
focusing on security.
As a Cloud engineer,
I've had the opportunity
to work with numerous customers
over the last few years.
One common request
among customers,
regardless of their
size or industry,
is to understand common
security best practices
and architectures.
A security professional
certification
not only provides Cloud
and security practitioners
with knowledge of the unique
features of GCP security
products but also goes
into great detail regarding
common industry
security practices.
The knowledge gained
from this exam
has enabled me to
help customers quickly
deploy their workloads on GCP in
a more safe and secure manner.
More recently, I've
been working with some
of our large
enterprise customers
in regulated industries.
With these customers,
I've learned
that virtually every
conversation is a security
conversation.
When designing a foundational
deployment, infrastructure
as code pipeline, or
data warehouse solution,
security can't simply
be added on at the end.
Security needs to be front
and center in the design.
Satisfying the strict and
exhaustive requirements
of these customers
often involves
interacting with
numerous security
teams, each with their own area
of concern and specific needs
and controls.
Designing solutions for these
teams that stitch together
the various requirements in
a logical and coherent manner
is a non-trivial exercise
that requires knowledge
across multiple facets
of cybersecurity.
The security professional
engineer certification
provides more than
just a service
level understanding
of these subjects.
It goes into great depth
regarding GCP products,
capabilities, and industry
best practices, which
will allow you to speak to the
needs of the various security
teams.
It provides building blocks to
design security architectures
that address common concerns
and the unique requirements
of a particular
customer or stakeholder.
I really think that the
professional Google Cloud
security engineer
certification can
benefit anyone working in Cloud,
even if you're not a security
practitioner.
Whether you have 20 developers
or 20,000 developers,
the security posture
of your environment
is of paramount importance.
Having employees with
security knowledge
adds another layer
of defense when
it comes to helping you
protect your critical data
and workloads.
The Security Professional
Certification
has been an
indispensable tool for me
when it comes to
designing better
solutions for our customers.
MARA SOSS: Gain
expertise and supercharge
your security career with
the Professional Google Cloud
Security Engineer certification.
Start preparing today with
30 days of free hands-on
on training available to you on
our on-demand learning platform
Google Cloud Skills Boost.
Best of luck on your training
and certification journey.